I'm Kohan Akagi engineer in smart news
Inc I'm doing developing the always in
mob news delivery of equation so using
especially machine learning or natural
language processing actually my back my
research background is not machine
learning kind of see but elementary
particle physics series so if you guys
have some interest in physics I can talk
about it later so today I'm gonna talk
about this topic globally scalable web
document classification using word to
deck because this talk is based on the
technology in smart news first let me
introduce about smartears
so smart news is the company developing
the iOS and Android application smart
news
how many guys use smart news here okay
very very few people how many guys love
machine learning here great great great
you will love machine I don't know you
will love smart news because smart news
is made by machine learning so smart
news is news up for more than 102
countries but there are no editors no
writers algorithm do everything so how
many guys uses news up every day not so
much actually yes almost all of the news
of pails and some of the news up have
great down roads but they are knowing
with low engagement ratio we smart news
has 10 million downloads globally and
more than 50 percent is active
so we can be successful news up right so
what makes us different what what is the
difference between smart news and other
news up the key word is machine learning
for discovery some news up uses editor
so they are not scalable and they can be
biased and some news up use machine
learning but they are using machine
learning for personalization we use
machine learning for discovery it is a
difference so we use machine learning
algorithm to make people to discover
well learn new things
it makes us different from other news so
our theory is that the algorithm for
discovery makes our engagement ratio
high so let me introduce the
demonstration over first
can you see okay so when you open it up
you see top news here so top news is
latest most important news which is
selected by our algorithm so here over
there over over here you see tabs for
each category entertainments positive
lifestyle us actually this is the most
straightforward result of our web
document classification and in this tab
you can see latest most important
articles for each category which is
selected by our algorithm so you see
that how precise the web our web
document classification should be right
if there is any mistake its it's bad so
this is a main topic of today one of the
cool thing of our app is that so when
you find what you want to eat let's say
you want to leave this you have smart
the option you may like this option
because it's clean and very simple we
also have web browser mode and it is
ordinary web browser when you see
article in there are so many things you
don't want to read right many ads many
banners many links so many things that
you don't want to read but in Smart View
it's very simple there is no ads no
banners you you may understand how
difficult to extract this Smart View
from a Vettori web document right so I
will talk about it later
so one another thing of which is cool
for smart people is that we can read
smart people in offline so you can read
smart people even in the airplane or
even in Metro anyway you can be smart
people so let's get back to the list ok
this is the end of the mo and let's get
back to the slides
as I already told you we have 10 million
downloads and 50% is active and we have
three types of Edition Japanese Edition
and US Edition and International Edition
and in international Edition users can
read articles in English in more than
100 countries which is localized to each
countries but again there are no editors
algorithm to everything so you guys good
it's Martin use SmartView is good but
what as I told you what makes us
different is our algorithm for discovery
so our algorithm to make people to
discover new things so this is the
outline of our algorithm for discovery
first URL is found from the internet
signals and HTML structure is unwise for
example the main Texas extracted images
extracted title is extracted and after
that semantics is analyzed for example
what category the article has what topic
what subject the article has or what
types of image the article has if it's
not semantics but we do analysis also
and after that by using the signals from
internet or semantics we calculate the
importance score of each article for
each category for each country and after
college maintain this score of each
article we diversify the topic of the
delivery list we don't want to deliver
the same topic article into one channel
so we to diversify the topic of the
articles and after that we deliver
articles to users
we troll three million articles per day
muu URLs per day but we only deliver
thousand articles to users the Rivoli
list is refreshed in real time so there
are so many things to talk about this
algorithm but today let's get into and I
will talk about for example probably be
how we do importance estimation we do
personalized we do another approach is
fully especially important because this
is related with our mission always so
why we'll talk about about it later
now let's get into today's topic
document classification the reason why I
choose word document classification
today is that document classification is
very important for our application as we
already see and for another reason
information retrieval form unstructured
data document is probably common tasks
for many applications so that's why I
choose this topic today so let's get
into web document classification the
task definition of web document
classification is very simple so when an
arbitrary web document arrives choose
one category exclusively from
predetermined category set very simple
right choose one category to one web
document this is the topic there are
roughly two steps to do web document
classification number one web contain
content extraction we have to extract
main content from unstructured data from
HTML it is very difficult because there
are so many websites and each website
have each different structures you know
so so many different structures so it's
very important and as we already seen we
we have smart beer in our apps and for
creating smart people this main content
extraction is very important
and number two we do text classification
so first I will briefly talk about main
content destruction and after that I
will talk about text classification
using the world through the text and the
model so let's start from main content
extraction so when we do main combat
extraction there are two types of
approach cheese and actually we used
bottom one the first one is extractor
after when rendering whole pages so
after rendering she says what JavaScript
images all of the things it's literally
this approach is relatively is easier
because we can use the information of
position or videos height of each
component so it's a little easy we can
easily extract the main content the
second approach is extract main content
from directory from HTML it's a more
difficult but it doesn't cost much
compute computation resource because we
have to analyze 10 million articles per
day let's say 100 article per second so
first is important so we use the second
apples so I will talk about
so the example of main content
extraction from HTML is like this so
detected which part is not main content
and detect which part is main content
it's easy so of course it is possible
rule based approaches possible define
rule like div which has text links more
than 22-hundred and number of attacks is
less than 3 is main content - blah blah
blah Ruby blah blah blah and brother
it's hard to define these rules it's
hard and we already told you we have
Japanese version and we will launch
another language and Ben will reveal to
the same scene in another language it's
really hard right so rule based approach
is possible but very hard not scalable
so we are using a machine learning
approach for doing this as one of the
algorithm so this machine learning
approach is based on the paper in 2011
so so I will talk about it this is yeah
I will talk about in training phase HTML
first HTML is separated into each text
text box and from each text book feature
vector is extracted so let's see this
book separation and feature extraction
part so as I told you for step 1 HTML is
separated into text box
and we can define there's many options
to define textbox but we use antics text
our definition of text Brooke is the
element which is sandwiched by block
level tag and after that we define the
local feature of every text book for
example local feature like word count
36 or a number of attack this in this
case this is 0 and after that for step 3
we define the feature vector for each
text drug as a combination of local
feature in other text program in this
example feature vector for each text
block is defined as the local feature of
current probe and previous broken this
is the feature vector so now we get so
in the training phase now we get feature
vector and labelled feature vectors they
built feature vectors level is main
content or not main content by using
this labelled feature vector we can
train decision tree when like that
realign beta comes new data comes by
using box separation separator and using
feature extractor feature vector for
each text block is extracted and by
using decision tree the main content is
exact that let's get into this part so
because we already got the feature
vector for each text block by using
decision tree feature from feature
vector a feature vector is classified
into
may or not may so we could get we can
know which text block is main content at
which textbook is not main content and
by combining the result of these
classification result we can get the
main content so probably everyone know
about this architecture but let me
review the overall architecture of text
classification first thing so in the
training phase we first prepare for
prepare the document set labeled
document sets and we in our case we
prepare the document sets by clothing
first we call the articles by our color
and our annotator annotate a category to
the document and after the in training
phase features extracted then labeled
feature sets are created and by using
training always in like logistic
regression or SVM classifiers is trained
when the live data comes by using the
same feature extractor features are
extracted and by using classifier the
category is obtained this is a very
simple overview of the classification
because the we used training always in
training articles and you use logistic
regression and it's very common and
there are so many material so I don't
talk about it today and I just focus on
this feature extra feature extraction
part today
as a feature vector bag-of-words is
commonly used backwards is a sets of
words in the document don't care about
what order very simple but it's not bad
if we want to improve the quality of the
let's say please join up text
classification we add for example stop
words or we add some dictionary we add
tf-idf like that in Japanese it is
similar we have to because Japanese is
not space separated language we have to
use some technique to separate each word
but after separating each word the
situation is similar we use pack of
words with some features but backwards
is definitely the perfect feature vector
right not perfect feature vector right
because for example it doesn't care
about word order or it doesn't care
about semantics for example the distance
between sports and soccer is the same as
the distance between sports and machine
learning so we wonder if there is better
feature extractor feature better or not
and we use progress vector as on another
option for better feature data and power
victor is what to back extended model it
is better better means the precision
text qualification precision in text
classification is better so I use we use
product better so let me introduce about
paragraph make them the example is like
that so every document every document is
mapped
into the tents several 100 tents mapped
in just dance better
so because progress better is what to
extend the model so let me first
increase cues about what to pack and
after that I will talk about paragraph
picture what to bed model when we use
word to that model every word is mapped
into unique dance worth vector in
paragraph vector case as I told you
every document is mapped into unique
vector so let's first talk about what to
back so every word is mapped to unit for
vector in this example France Paris
Germany's that means I'm opting to unit
vector and what is surprising is that
the future like future like Germany my
Experion equals to france - paris it's
surprising by this nature we assure that
the some semantics is embedded in the
world vector so the procedure to create
word back was better in world Subic is
like this so first we prepare for the
sets of document and label each word w1
w2 blah blah blah like that and after
that maximize the objective function l
in this object function large d means
the number words in the whole document
and she is arbitrary number two or three
is commonly used maximizing this
objective function l means that
maximizing the probability to predict a
word from surrounding words for example
in the light figure example while
training the model is refreshed
so that the probability predict on from
surrounding Wars cats at the street
becomes higher so as a probability
function this p is used this p is every
words had ineffectively in the outer
bacter you and lovely speaking after
training converge the more a pair of
words shows up in the one sentence the
larger the inner product of you and
three for two words becomes so after
maximizing the objective function we can
get the optimized value of you and three
for each word w and we use blue as a
world vector for w and actually
technically speaking to maximize this of
the objective function l costs too much
the bottom bottom part of exponential
the some of the some of you some w cost
heavy so we have to use some
approximation they to there are two
types of public approximation one is
here are cows soft mass and one is
negative something but it's beyond the
scope of this talk so this is the way to
create well better by using wall to that
model
then let's get into public vector model
so as I told you every document is
mapped into one dance better procedure
to create proper vector is similar to
what to take case first we prepare for
the document said and we label each
world w1 w2 like that and we also label
each document as document one document -
like that and we maximize the objective
function l the difference from what to
that case is that the objective function
includes the document ID doc underbar
and score I here so maximizing the this
objective function means that maximizing
the probability to predict a word not
only form disheartening words but also
from document itself the model of
probability function is like this and it
is also different from what - that one
difference is that it includes the
document vector here so each word has
like water becase each word has in a
vector and a vector and the talk each
document has its own document vector and
we maximize L for you and 3 and W and we
can get the optimized party loyalty you
and three for each word and D for each
document and we use P we D is a problem
better but we get
we get a paragraph vector for each
document but what we want to do is not
this because we it is we get now we get
the part of victories for that's not
what we want right
what we want is when new document comes
extract part of vector from document
right so for doing this we need another
step
so after this this process you know I
mean maximizing l and we can we get
optimized Mario view and three and D
when we new document comes we label the
document like that we want w to again
and then we maximize this l talk this
objective function l doc we don't need
to maximize this l doc or you and do it
because we already have the optimized
spider love you and three oh we have to
do it just maximize this function for T
and we get the optimized value P and
this is the paragraph vector for that
document probably it's a little bit
complicated so I draw a very simple
picture here so I agree we put the large
document sets into the International we
trained the feature extractor and by
using the feature extract when new
document comes Parker vector is
extracted it's very simple white it's
it's a simple picture of training
getting the paragraph vector for
training features but in our data case
dataset we use 100 thousand documents
and it takes
in laptop it takes only three hours or
four hours it doesn't take much and for
extracting Parker picked up from new
document it takes only several
milliseconds so it doesn't take take
time so after obtaining feature vector
paragraph vector by using part of vector
as a feature vector we can use T we can
do the ordinary text classification like
this I want to say talk about the good
point and Pat point of using paragraph
if from the point of operation the good
thing is actually the high precision in
text classification in our data set the
precision of text classification is
better than using backup first so it's
good and for another thing high scale of
80 is very important because we don't
need to work hard to do feature
engineering for each language all we
have to do is just prepare the sets of
document it's great in no use case we
use paragraph vector as by combination
with the bug reports crossfire so for
example in some use case we use
combination of each classifier like
using more reliable result of to
classifiers poop for squares versus park
effective based classifier and another
hour another use case is partition use
one to validate the other it's all and
of future use cases we do it in
multilingual vocalization in
multilingual localization when we do
that we don't want to do feature
engineering we don't want to do
yeah I work hard on speech engine
engineering life so using only pug a
vector based classifier is actually
possible from the point of operation
it's it's really good so this is the end
of the text classification and probably
actually we should we should search for
we should try first but actually
Japanese in English is very different
right
probably it's good in Spanish it's not
so different from English so it's I
don't know about the Arabic indeed it's
expectation III I didn't try
I'm sure you do nothing yeah
so for doing the yeah I'm doing that we
are doing that for backup worst case
actually forward to that case we don't
do anything all we do is just about each
word by space
so this is the end of the text
classification part now let me talk
about our challenge as I told you news
news is uncertainty seeking for long
term peruse what if you keep hearing
only opinions that much yours
what if parents don't feel vegetables
for children who only likes me
so what other big data company is doing
is suggest what users already have
interest right using for example matrix
matrix factorization like we don't want
to do that what we want to do is make
user to discover another thing discovery
for our algorithm to discovery is what
makes us different but it's really
challenging task you know so for doing
that we are developing them first we
have to get better feature better for
users and article 14 that we are doing
topics brushing up the topic extraction
always and more image extraction Airways
and like that and for another thing we
are doing the algorithm to explore the
users interest space by using
multi-armed bandit always and paste
scoring model so actually we have we
have to create a model which includes 10
million feature vector of 10 million
users and feature real-time feature
vector of articles it's challenging I
guess yeah it's yeah I'm sure it's very
challenging as it's very interesting
that's not just do the matrix
factorization we
have to create the model to explore the
users interspace for example by using
panda and we have to calculate this big
data so it's very challenging task but
we have only five engineers taco on this
problem there are many engineers but few
tacos alone this problem is only five
engineers including machine learning PhD
because on their swings cherry PhD
initially massage you hey is here and me
only five people so really we need much
much much much much much more people to
tackle this problem so so we are hiring
so much taco taco on this program so we
need more much more machine learning NLP
engineer and we need more data science
engineer so it's our our character it's
Keuka yeah so feel free to contact me
and now now oh this is chicken
so finally we have CEO here so please
see how our CEO moves hi I'm Kai say
Hamamoto the technical co-founder of
smart news I'm so pleased we managed to
successfully launch smart news in the US
with more than 1 million monthly active
users after quickly growing in Japan now
we have more than 10 new global users
with 5 million monthly active users and
really God machine learning as big part
of its growth but please let me give a
little context of how we think
differently slightly differently about
machine learning a number of companies
have been trying to take full advantage
of machine learning in order to cater to
each users interest in consuming content
and as a result users tend to easily
fall into a pitfall of so-called filter
bubble as you know and in the short term
it might be a good thing because it can
maximize the time spent on their product
and maximize user engagement but in the
wrong term especially when it comes to
news it might be a problem we think
because we believe that the secret to
getting news right is discovery not
personalization so we in other words we
need to solve very difficult problem of
exploitation and exploration trade-off
with the hope of delivering the quality
news or quirky information to the people
who need it in the world and we do that
by machine learning if you are
interested please talk to me afterward
thank you very much